para los dos modelos opuestos chocan en
chile- en la recta final de la campaña
hacia la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales la derecha
extrema representada por josé antonio
kast y la izquierda de la alianza entre
el frente amplio y el partido comunista
por gabriel boric se enfrentan con dos
programas dispares cast ha buscado
mostrar su cara más moderada modificando
algunas de sus propuestas más polémicas
como la eliminación del ministerio de la
mujer pero manteniendo su mano dura en
contra de la migración sosteniendo la
creación de una zanja en la frontera en
nuestro programa de gobierno siempre lo
dijimos no estaba escrito en piedra
siempre fueron propuestas para políticas
públicas que queríamos entregarle a la
ciudadanía ellas son mejorables por su
lado boric reitero algunas de sus
banderas no militarizar a el sur de
chile uno de los puntos que defiende su
contendor sin embargo bajó el tono a sus
propuestas desligándose parcialmente de
su idea de indultar a los manifestantes
detenidos a las protestas de 2019 y se
mostró abierto al diálogo hay quienes
han tratado de e instalar que esta es
una disputa ente extremos yo no soy un
extremo yo soy una persona que como he
demostrado a lo largo mi trayectoria
busca grandes acuerdos entre quienes
piensan distinto en función de un bien
común el objetivo de los dos candidatos
conseguir los votos del electorado del
centro de los indecisos y al cerca del
50% de las personas habilitadas para
votar que no asistieron a las urnas los
políticos buscan revertir la corta
diferencia de dos puntos porcentuales
que posicionó al conservador como
ganador de la primera vuelta
por ahora boric se ha llevado el apoyo
de los partidos de la oposición mientras
que la coalición gobernante anunció que
respaldará casta